[Applaudissements]
on va se faire un petit quizz je vous
fais un quiz faites entrer l'accusé ou
l'amour et c'est à dire je vous propose
un personnage en pointe des photos vous
me dîtes si c'est des gars qui ont fait
fait l'entrée l'accusé où l'amour est
dans le pré
d'accord je suis première photo assure
non premières photos s'il vous plaît je
prêt oui le pré c'était bien ce rallye
que j'aime beaucoup
j'adorerais faire un prix le prix oui
c'est pascal dupraz deuxième accusé ben
oui c'est vrai que j'adore elle est usée
elle croit qu'elle est d'un mot de passe
un autre mot après trois mairies oui
c'est robert spall ski ça vous l'avez
reconnu ou pas qui a tué au moins quatre
personnes aux états unis
il est actuellement au pénitencier de
new york si vous le cherchez troisième
alors va-t-on trouver l'amour est dans
le pré mais a démenti c'est le prêt à
l'amour est dans le pré
oui le prêt oui il est sympa philippe
aime bien aller à l'étude je dois
contribuer à cette demande devient
crossover savait qu il a fait les deux
l'effort se souvient lâche enfin que
j'allais en fait il n'a pas fait voeu
adopté l'idée là il a participé à
l'amour est dans le pré en belgique
mais il a aussi tué son patron patron eh
ouais regardez on a l'expérience extrême
n'ont commenté me mets à huy tanks et
quoi comment une émission que j'ai passé
une cour d'assises oui d'accord
chose que je n'étais pas expliqué dans
la lettre j'aurais bien lui-même
discuter avec l'eau suite à mon premier
travail
j'ai eu un gros problème avec mon
supérieur est gelée malheureusement tu
es encore qui a croqué coutu lire aussi
ça déjà refroidi 250 personnes j'étais
sous les pressions sous médicaments et
sous l'emprise de la boisson à vaujours
ben j'ai vu noir j'ai pété un câble
voilà donc je sais que ça fait froid
dans le dos à beaucoup de gens
[Applaudissements]